now to the first part of a series you'll
see here every Wednesday in the month of
March focusing on men in America the
signs are everywhere if you're a
middle-aged man you probably know appear
who has killed himself in recent years
at least one if you're a parent you may
have noticed that your daughter's
friends seem a little more on the ball
than your sons they get better grades
they smoke much less marijuana they
spend less time playing video games they
go to more prestigious colleges if
you're an employer you may have noticed
that your female employees show up on
time the young men often don't and of
course if you live in this country
you've just seen a horrifying series of
mass shootings far more than we've ever
had women didn't do that in every case
the shooter was a man something ominous
is happening to men in America everyone
who pays attention knows that what's odd
is how rarely you hear it publicly
acknowledged our leaders pledged to
create more opportunities for women and
girls whom they imply are failing men
don't need help they're the patriarchy
they're fine more than fine but are they
fine here are the numbers start with the
most basic life and death the average
American man will die five years before
the average American woman one of the
reasons for this is addiction men are
more than twice as likely as women to
become alcoholics
they're also twice as likely to die of a
drug OD in New Hampshire one of the
state's hardest hit by the opioid crisis
73% of overdose deaths were men but the
saddest reason for shortened lifespans
is suicide 77% of all suicides in
America are committed by men the overall
rate is increasing at a dramatic pace
between 1997 and 2014 there was a 43
percent rise in suicide deaths among
middle-aged American men the rates are
highest among American Indian and white
men who killed themselves at about 10
times the rate of Hispanic and black
women you often hear America's
incarceration crisis well that's almost
exclusively a male problem to over 90
percent of inmates are men
now these problems are complex but we
know that they start young and relative
to girls boys are failing in school more
girls than boys graduate high school
considerably more go to and graduate
from college in schools at every level
boys account for the overwhelming
majority of discipline cases one study
found that fully one in five high school
boys had been diagnosed with some form
of hyperactivity disorder that's
compared with just one in eleven girls
many of them were medicated for it the
long-term health effects those
medications not fully understood but
they do appear to include depression in
later life women now decisively
outnumber men in graduate school they
are in the majority of doctoral degrees
they're now the majority of new
enrollees in both law and medical
schools for men the consequences of
failing in school are long-term and
profound between 1979 and 2010 working
age men with only high school degrees so
they're real hourly wages drop about 20
percent over the same period high school
educated women saw their wages rise the
decline of the industrial economy
disproportionately hurt men there are
now 7 million working-age men in America
who don't work they've dropped out of
the labor force nearly half of them take
pain medication on any given day that is
the highest rate in the world by far far
fewer young men get married than did
just a few decades ago and fewer stay
married about 1 in 5 American children
live now only with their mothers that's
double the rate of 1970 millions more
boys growing up without fathers young
adult men are now more likely to live
with a parent than they are to live with
a spouse or a partner that is not the
case for young women single women buy
their own homes at more than twice the
rate of single men more women than men
now have driver's licenses
whenever gender differences come up in
public debate the so called wage gap
seems to dominate the conversation
you've heard it a woman makes 77 cents
for every dollar a man earns that's the
statistic that you'll hear a lot
presidents have repeated it many
candidates it's everywhere and yet that
number compares all American men to All
American women across all professions
no illegitimate social science
just would consider that a valid or
meaningful measure the number doesn't
mean anything it's intentionally
misleading it's a talking point once you
compare men and women with similar
experience working the same hours and
similar jobs for the same period of time
that's the only way you can measure it
the gap all but disappears in fact it
may invert one study using census data
found that single women in their 20s
living in metropolitan areas now earn 8%
more on average than their male
counterparts by the way the majority of
managers in the workplace are now women
women on average or scoring higher on IQ
tests than men are even physically men
are falling behind a recent study found
that almost half of young men failed the
Army's entry level physical fitness exam
during basic training fully 70 percent
of American men are now overweight or
obese that's compared to 59 percent of
American women perhaps was bafflingly
and terrifyingly men seem to becoming
less male fundamentally measurably sperm
counts for example across the West have
plummeted they're down almost 60% since
the early 1970s scientists don't know
why this is testosterone levels in men
have also fallen precipitously one study
found that average levels of male
testosterone dropped by one percent
every year after 1987 and it's not
related to age in other words the
average 40 year old man in 2017 would
have testosterone levels 30% lower than
the average 40 year old man in 1987
there is no upside to this trend lower
testosterone levels in men are
associated with depression lethargy
weight gain decreased cognitive ability
nothing like this has ever happened to a
population in this big so you'd think
we'd want to know exactly why what's
going on how do we fix it and yet the
media ignore that story it's considered
a fringe topic somehow nor is it believe
it or not a priority in the scientific
research establishment we checked and we
couldn't find a single NIH funded study
on why testosterone levels are falling
we did find this study on quote pubic
hair grooming prevalence and motivation
among women in the u.s. so those are the
numbers and they paint a very clear
picture
American men are failing in body in mind
and in spirit this is a crisis yet our
leaders pretend it's not happening and
in fact they tell us the opposite is
true women are victims men are
oppressors
to question that assumption is to risk
punishment even as women far outpace men
in higher education for example
virtually every college campus supports
a Women's Studies department whose core
goal is to attack male power our
politicians and business leaders
internalize and amplify that message men
are privileged women are oppressed hire
and promote and reward accordingly now
that would be fine if it were true but
it's not true
at best it's an outdated view of an
America that no longer exists
at worst it's a pernicious lie either
way ignoring the decline of men does not
help anyone men and women need each
other one cannot exist without the other
that is elemental biology it's also the
reality that each one of us has lived
with their parents and siblings and
friends when men fail all of us suffer
how did this happen how can we fix it we
hope that this series each Wednesday
this month answers those questions